york city mayor eric adams blasting
black lives matter for being silent and
not protesting rising shootings and
murders that have impacted the
african-american community watch if
black lives matters then the thousands
of people i saw on the street
when floyd was murdered should be on the
street right now say stating that the
lives of these black children that are
dying every night matters it can't be
hypocrite
democrats have been trying to pivot away
from defund the police and embrace law
and order as rising crime becomes a huge
issue in the midterms just look at this
insane scene in los angeles a woman
chased down after leaving a jewelry
store hit by a car the thieves making
off with her watch
police say street gangs have been
targeting residents in wealthy areas
does
the mayor have a point here lawrence and
are we seeing blatant hypocrisy play out
and communities that are not adequately
protected
i mean
the mayor is just saying what black
people have been saying for a while now
um
to his credit he has been critical of
black lives matter before
but
let's be very clear of who was funding
black lives matter because it was not
black people that was funding black
lives matter it was white corporations
and white people funding them because
they didn't want to do the work in the
community black people said we just want
equal justice under the law
in return people supported the
organization when we really never really
supported the organization they promised
50 billion dollars to the organization
now you got patrice culler's going out
there saying that the irs is targeting
them when we know they've gone out to
the tea party and every other group i
just think that there's a lesson to be
learned about black land because i think
the organization is officially dead
right now they took the theme of what
black people were feeling and turned it
into their own little money cash cow
um
i think that this is the end for them
and i think it should be a lesson to
people do the work don't think you just
cut a check and somehow things are just
going to disappear all right but how do
you keep kids safe
well you got to support your law
enforcement the molly
my criticism is why would you even call
them out you're asking charity and help
from a ponzi scam and we all know what
it is they're not going to help anyone
they help themselves and you're going to
see when they go to jail it's not going
to be not going to be brothers and
sisters across the country having to
turn checks back in or school books and
computers back in that they bought and
didn't do their taxes on no they're
going to be auctioning off their
mansions their cars their planes because
it was
the ugliest part of any any culture
group not just blacks
white's got to deal with it too they
crazy they say we're here for the people
and they're there to load their pockets
and move their own agendas at the
expense of everyone else so he shouldn't
even wasted his time mentioning black
lives matters because they've never come
out to support black on black crime to
support poverty to support brothers who
can't afford lawyers they've never done
that the only time they've come out is
when you have a white cop and a black
suspect in an issue that goes wrong
because that gets attention that gets
super elitist to write checks and that
gives them the right to do and say
anything and that's the only time they
come out period because it's a good way
it's a good hustle all right so when we
find our way because you had a lot of
people in the streets protesting in the
summer of 2020 they wanted to make their
voices heard they wanted to do the right
thing
and they wanted to be
allies but you also had with that the
defund the police movement that did so
much harm not only to law enforcement
but the most vulnerable communities when
there wasn't as much as much proactive
policing now the president and some
moderate democrats are trying to
backtrack on that and they're trying to
say no now we need to fund the police so
how do we find our way out of this
we just listen to jim clyburn
jim clyburn always understands certainly
where the pulse of the democratic party
is but really the middle of the country
what turned into to be
the biden coalition right the moderate
republicans the independents and the
democrats who could come together in
agreement on this issue and he said to
people like representatives cory bush
and elanomar stop talking about these
things it's not even actually
what you mean
you know you're talking about people who
represent communities where i guess
that's fine for them but that is not the
overwhelming percentage of communities
that have a large black or brown
population and it was really interesting
pugh just released new numbers on the
top priority issues for black americans
number one violence and crime at 17
number two economic issues at 11
if you look at the numbers for white
americans it's reversed we all know that
inflation and cost of living etc are the
top priorities there and the democrats
are sitting here thinking we're heading
into a midterms where we could lose up
to you know some people are projecting
up to 60 seats these are the kinds of
issues that on the offense voters are
looking
for you to pay to pay attention to them
about and black voters i'm not saying
they're going to go and suddenly support
republicans only about 10 ideas
republicans but it can't make you stay
home so if you don't feel like
why don't they support the organization
though i'm just curious why we're
talking about this decided to give their
money to these organizations when black
people never said that they support it
they had there was a cause not the
organization they want to get rid of
black men out of the households
i don't understand how you could stand
for black men in the street and didn't
want to remove them out of the household
right they went there sorry
jessica talks about the biden coalition
which is completely fallen apart if you
look at the most recent quinnipiac poll
26
of latino respondents support the
president that is an incredibly low
number yeah so you know he's he's turned
his back on a lot of people including
the cops and he was running for
president is there is this the way for
him to get out of an incredible slump
it's too late it's too late biden's not
getting out of the slump i disagree
clyburn doesn't have an answer clyburn
never said
don't defund the police he never said
you gotta refund the police let's be
real clear on that you want to read
between the lines you can do that but
you can't you can't do it here number
one there's a difference between the
organization and the movement okay we
all believe in the movement the
organization was a bunch of shysters
okay we've got patricia colors who
bought at least three houses she bought
one that was for sale for 3.1 million
dollars she bought it a week later at
2.7 million dollars more for 5.8 million
dollars who got that 2.7 million i don't
know she put it in the name of michelle
corporation that famous law firm the
democrat law firm perkins coy did the
shell corporation she lived in it she
hid it from the black lives matter
organization for 19 months all right and
she didn't let anyone know that she had
purchased it now as for eric adams this
is the first time the first time i heard
this guy talk about black on black crime
and mayor it's about time it's about
time you recognize that that is the
biggest problem in the criminal justice
system and maybe it's because as you
said you were up all night and now
you're facing it for real everybody
assumed because he was a cop and a
police captain he got it well he didn't
get it until he finally sent it number
three you've got to refund the police
because we've got a 60 spiking crime i
don't want to hear about women being
almost run over by gangs in in los
angeles and it's happening here because
they're wearing a watch that someone
wants because criminals are emboldened
because democrats were silent in 2020
during the black lives matter uh burning
of streets and peaceful protests and now
this is what we're left with and it's
time to get back on the straight narrow
consequences for criminals change the
cash bail laws refund the police and put
some organization into law enforcement
and let everybody know you cross the
line your ass is going to jail enough
said all right judge hopefully you'll
find your passion on this topic at some
point judge i'm still very very hopeful
hey guess what the fastest is up next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else